us definitely have to send out more for
more actions
otherwise
if
he's not going to stop on ukraine
everybody knows that i don't want only
americans i want the whole world to wake
up because it's a threat to the whole
world putin will not stop thrashing
bumps my family and friends now in kiev
and many
cities of ukraine and i want the whole
world to know that this is time to act
and not to discuss and not only make
photos and hashtags and on facebook and
twitter we need to act because we're
protecting not only ukraine but the
whole western civilization
[Music]
i support ukraine
i came here
today to
ask
our president to
have
to to impose
uh better sanctions uh on russia because
the sanctions that he announced today
earlier today
are not really enough i i'm speechless i
mean
i don't know what to say putin is like
it's an executive hitler
it's unbelievable and we're pretty sure
there's more than that usa can do for us
despite the fact we respect you say and
thank them for everything that they have
done but we're sure there are more
serious acts that may be done to support
ukraine all my family is in ukraine and
they're
very scared
and we don't know what's going to happen
to them so
here we must do everything we can to
help and support ukraine we need um usa
to react not just the sanctions
won't really do anything
i just want to support my country
i'm here it just so happens that i work
here right now
and
i mean i send money
and this is the least i can do i guess
we just want to
incorporate more sanctions and more
coordinates with u.n everyone is
trying to find
a place to hide
stocking up on food since there is not
much options will be in the next few
days
they will be disconnected from the
internet
water will be
cut off electricity so
that means that they have to find
options they're doing so far okay but
you know stay ready for any minute for
anything
we have all our loved ones that are
sitting in the
shelters and trying to survive the night